what do you think it was about the 80s
about that time between the wrestling
thing and the movies you did what was so
cool about the 80s that so many people
obviously myself included have such like
great nostalgia for for that time
well the raid that what happened was
wrestling went national all of a sudden
it had been in 26 regionalised
territories it had come out of the
carnival world it had gone into the 26
regionalized territories and all these
promoters 26 of them really were kind of
like the Mafia
nobody ever crossed their lines and then
in the 80s came young Vince McMahon jr.
the son of Vince McMahon's senior while
he didn't owe nobody any allegiance and
he had a vision and along with that came
cable television he started buying up
cable TV and he took wrestling national
and he took it to levels we never I'll
never forget the night we did NBC the
first night NBC Saturday night main
event I remember we altered where we
alternated every three to four weeks was
Saturday Night Live and the greatest one
ever was the second season they had
Madonna opening up Saturday Night Live
she was red-hot we came on three weeks
later and blew her numbers right out of
the water to this day
wrestling Saturday night main event has
the highest ratings for what they call a
weekend special we actually did what was
it a 34 share Wow I mean we you know we
always think about the Golden Age of TV
and and but that really was the the
Golden Age of wrestling although it's it
seems to be having a pretty nice
comeback my final question for you I'm
gonna end you on a big one who's running
the show who's running the show I know
you're a conspiracy guy I know you know
a lot about everything who really at the
end of the day is run is is this the
government is this the Illuminati who's
it running the show you know I can't sit
Dave and tell you I can tell you who's
doing it and I used to not believe in
that Illuminati I used to not believe in
world government and that they were out
there but I've somewhat changed my mind
now in the investigations I've done and
the things I've watched and seen and I'm
62 years old now
it seems to me mighty strange I don't
believe that our president runs our
country anymore because the classic
example was Barack Obama when he ran now
he said he would close Gitmo he said he
would do all of these things and then
the moment he got in office those things
were all forgotten our foreign policy
there's no difference in our foreign
policy between George Bush and Barack
Obama at all none whatsoever and so
somebody else and to me it's got to be
the powerful money people it's got to be
the Federal Reserve and the bankers who
control the money because if you control
the money you control everything